The Justice League is vaporized in a
single blast and Mr. Fantastic ends up
a pile of blue spaghetti. It's been a rough
year for superheroes. Here's who's dead.
Like his sons Thor and Loki, Odin appears
in Marvel comics and movies, DC comics,
various works of fantasy, and, of course, Norse
mythology. MCU viewers associate the All-Father
with Anthony Hopkins' portrayal in the first three
"Thor" movies. As is the case with Asgard itself,
Marvel's Odin goes through cycles of destruction
and rebirth. He dematerializes into particles
of bright light at the beginning of "Thor:
Ragnarok," and similarly wills himself out
of existence at the conclusion of 2022's "Thor"
#22, by writer Donny Cates and artist Nic Klein.
"I'm on a different path now.
This you must face alone."
In this penultimate installment of Cates' "God
of Hammers" arc, Odin reveals that his continued
existence is preventing Thor, the current king
of Asgard, from wielding the full cosmic might
usually at the disposal of his royal station.
Recognizing that Thor needs an extra boost to
defeat the renegade God of Hammers, a blend
of Mjolnir's energy and the nefarious Mangog,
Odin releases the last of his power to
his son, erasing himself in the process.
In 2016's "Suicide Squad," only two members
of Task Force X bite the big one. In contrast,
2021's "The Suicide Squad" includes a wholesale
massacre of DC C-list baddies. Fortunately,
this slaughter does not include Peacemaker,
allowing him to return for his HBO Max series.
Perhaps in the interest of consistency
with the film, "Peacemaker" ends
Season 1 with fewer characters than it
starts. Most of these characters are
ordinary humans or members of the hostile
alien race colloquially known as butterflies.
The butterfly Ik Nobe Llok, who inhabits
the body of ex-mercenary Clemson Murn,
is sort of both. And in many respects, his
ultimately self-sacrificing quest to prevent
his fellow butterflies from annihilating
the human race qualifies as super-heroic.
After the butterflies take over the
police force of Evergreen, Washington,
Murn throws himself under the metaphorical
bus to allow Harcourt and Adebayo to
evade execution and carry on with
their mission. In a tragic twist,
the butterfly Eek Stack Ik Ik — sometimes referred
to as "Goff" and inhabiting the body of Detective
Sophie Song — happens to be the individual
who repeatedly pulls the trigger on Murn.
We haven't seen a ton of super-pets
since 1985's "Crisis on Infinite Earths"
reset the DC universe's timeline and removed them
from officially-recognized existence. So
it's nice to see Krypto the Superdog and
Comet the Super-Horse make something of a
comeback in 2021's "Supergirl: Woman of Tomorrow."
The eight-issue epic sends Kara Zor-El on a
galaxy-spanning journey. She's determined to
track down Krem, an interstellar pirate who
needlessly slew her friend's father, then
poisoned Krypto while making his escape.
By the time the final issue arrives,
Supergirl has successfully detained Krem.
However, Krem manages to send for a cavalry
of space pirates to help reverse his
fortune. After a significant struggle,
Supergirl manages to dispatch these baddies,
but Comet loses his life in the process.
It's a little ambiguous whether "Supergirl:
Woman of Tomorrow" is a canonical tale,
so this Comet's precise nature
is difficult to pin down.
But Supergirl does mention that she knew
he was a man cursed to live as a horse,
a fact he didn't love talking about. This death
might not stick, but it's still enormously moving.
Netflix threw its hat into the superhero satire
ring with 2022's "The Guardians of Justice."
Reminiscent of "The Boys," "Invincible," and
HBO's "Watchmen," "The Guardians of Justice"
doesn't treat the cape-and-cowl set as spotless
heroes. Marvelous Man, this universe's Superman
equivalent, seemingly dies live on television,
but some of his colleagues suspect foul play.
"I'm tired. So I found my escape."
"No. Don't do this, Cal!"
"I found it."
Much like Rorschach's search for the
Comedian's killer kicks off "Watchmen,"
"The Guardians of Justice" joins Knight Hawk as
he explores the mystery of Marvelous Man's death.
But who is Marvelous Man? He arrived on Earth
after his home planet was destroyed by a
Brainiac-like villain. Like any wannabe Superman
worth his salt, Marvelous Man can fly, has heat
vision, boasts seemingly impossible strength, and
is virtually invulnerable to all potential harm,
except for this world's Kryptonite equivalent.
The copyright-safe version of a Kryptonite bullet
that kills him is ostensibly stolen from a
stand-in for Lex Luthor. Sound bizarre? It
is. But that's "The Guardians of Justice" in
a copyright-safe, kryptonite-laced nutshell.
In 2022's "The Human Target," private
investigator Christopher Chance, aka
the Human Target, ingests a slow-acting
poison intended for Lex Luthor.
He has 12 days to figure out who's to
blame for his rapidly approaching death,
and the hardboiled gumshoe suspects the
involvement of at least one member of
Justice League International. The ensuing tale
blends elements of noir detective traditions and
the irreverent side of DC publishing that
emerged in the late 1980s and early 1990s.
Whether or not Tom King and Greg Smallwood's
miniseries takes place in the mainstream
DC timeline is unclear. Therefore,
Guy Gardner may appear in another,
more canonical story before the end of the
year, or even reemerge somehow in "The Human
Target." Nevertheless, the fact remains
that the Green Lantern Corps' biggest
jerk is killed in a fight with Ice, his ex,
and Chris Chance in "The Human Target" #6.
Originally one of Christopher's suspects, subzero
superheroine Ice eventually becomes his romantic
interest, much to Guy's jealous fury. The
third-most famous Green Lantern attacks the
new couple after a night of passion, only to find
himself frozen solid and shattered to pieces,
in that order. Let that be a lesson
to awful exes everywhere, nothing good
ever comes from stalking and harassment,
even if you have a power ring from space.
Plenty of folks who'd like to get into
superhero comics find themselves stymied by
DC and Marvel's convoluted continuity, jarring
reboots, and reliance upon obscure characters with
omnipotent powers appearing from out of
nowhere. They've got a new hurdle to clear,
courtesy of "Justice League #75" by Joshua
Williamson and Rafa Sandoval. In this issue,
a previously benevolent dimensional traveler
named Pariah effortlessly dematerializes a
sizeable fraction of DC's best-known,
usually-unstoppable champions of virtue.
Specifically, Pariah kills the Justice League.
Superman, Batman, Wonder Woman, Green Lantern,
Zatanna, Aquaman, Hawkgirl, and the Martian
Manhunter all evaporate into nothing. He also
bumps off multidimensional Justice Leaguers
including President Superman of Earth-23,
Doctor Multiverse of Earth-8, Captain
Carrot of Earth-23, and a handful of others.
Promotional materials tell us this
ghastly, traumatizing massacre of
globally beloved characters leads into
DC's summer of 2022 event, "Dark Crisis."
All of this is plenty shocking by itself, but
here's the kicker, current "Action Comics"
scribe Phillip Kennedy Johnson has already
made it known, via an interview with CBR,
that Superman's death will in no way interrupt
Kal-El's noble struggle against intergalactic
tyranny and oppression in his concurrent
"Warworld Saga." Likewise, ceasing to exist
doesn't seem to be stopping Batman from hunting
Ra's al Ghul's assassin in the "Shadow War"
multi-series crossover. DC's most prominent heroes
have died in "Justice League." Somehow, they all
continue to prosper in their solo adventures.
What gives? We suppose we'll have to keep reading.
Fans of the Fantastic Four have waited years for
Marvel's First Family to take their rightful place
at the center of the MCU, and they probably
won't have to stay patient for much longer.
Even though it's currently in need of a
new director, "Marvel's Fantastic Four"
should come to fruition within the not-so-distant
future. Hopefully the version of Reed Richards
from the mainstream MCU timeline fares a
little better than the Reed who leads the
Illuminati from Earth-838 because that
guy dies a swift and humiliating death.
In "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness," the Scarlet Witch chases Steven
Strange and America Chavez to Earth-838, hoping to
use America's dimension-hopping powers to reunite
with her sons. Earth-838's Illuminati,
a secretive group of elite superheroes,
do not initially take the threat of the Scarlet
Witch seriously. If they can beat Thanos, how much
of a problem could Wanda Maximoff possibly be,
right? As it happens, the Scarlet Witch controls
reality itself, so she turns Reed into string
cheese and then makes his brains explode.
The Inhumans TV show is the biggest abject
failure in MCU history, and there isn't a close
second. The X-Men's movie rights returning
to Marvel pretty much destroys any remaining
chance of the Inhumans occupying the MCU's
lane for genetically gifted outcasts.
And Black Bolt probably died the most
gruesome and unsettling demise of any
Illuminati member in "Multiverse of
Madness," which is saying something.
After Reed Richards of Earth-838 informs Wanda
that Black Bolt can annihilate her with a whisper.
Wanda simply smirks and uses her magic.
"What mouth?"
The king of the Inhumans then notices
that his mouth has vanished. He panics,
and the resulting yelp causes his skull to pop
like a blister. We don't think the mainstream MCU
timeline's Black Bolt, also played by Anson Mount,
would ever be dumb enough to use his unfathomably
destructive vocal cords while his mouth was
sewn shut. He might be a commercial failure,
but the Black Bolt of the ABC television network
is probably way harder to kill than this guy.
Since arriving on the scene in 2011's
"Captain America: The First Avenger,"
Peggy Carter has journeyed from movies to
network television to streaming animation.
While anyone who watched ABC's "Agent Carter"
can attest to the combat prowess of the version
of Peggy who resides in the regular MCU timeline,
the Peggy variant from "What if... Captain Carter
Were the First Avenger?" would probably be
more useful in a fight against Dr. Doom.
The Disney+ series "What If...?" tells us the
tale of Captain Carter, a time-displaced World
War II-era hero who's injected with the super
soldier-serum when the original test subject,
Steve Rogers, is made temporarily
unavailable. However, we can safely
presume the events of "What If...?" are not
directly connected to conditions on Earth-838.
Captain Carter is slated for significant
amounts of screen time in "What If...?"
Season 2, and the Earth-838 variant of Peggy is
all out of time, screen-related or otherwise.
Relative to the other Illuminati members, Captain
Carter puts up a decent fight against the Scarlet
Witch. She even manages to land a few strikes
before Wanda takes telepathic control of Captain
Carter's signature shield and uses it to separate
Peggy's lower half from the rest of her torso.
In the primary MCU timeline, Maria Rambeau
is Carol Danvers' friend, and the mother
of Monica Rambeau. She sadly passes away during
the years between "Infinity War" and "Endgame,"
but not before making a big impact in the world
of the MCU by founding S.W.O.R.D. In Earth-838,
Maria became Captain Marvel instead of Carol
Danvers, and she went on to join Reed Richards'
Illuminati. Sharing the attitude of the rest of
her pompous secret society, Maria tells Strange
they "can handle your little witch" if Wanda
Maximoff shows up looking for America Chavez.
As it turns out, Earth-838's
Captain Marvel can't handle the
"little witch," who squashes Captain
Marvel by dropping a statue on her.
Somewhat curiously, Earth-838 Maria wears a
teal-colored costume similar to the uniform Carol
Danvers fights in during her time as the amnesiac
Kree warrior Vers in 2019's "Captain Marvel."
In theory, this could indicate that
some sort of diplomatic relationship
exists between the Kree and
the governments of Earth-838,
but who knows if we'll ever hear
more about this timeline's history?
Patrick Stewart played Professor Charles
Xavier for the first time back in the year
2000's "X-Men" and once said he'd step away from
the role after the high note of 2017's "Logan."
Apparently, Kevin Feige used mind control
abilities of his own to convince Stewart to
play Xavier for the eighth time in
"Multiverse of Madness." Although,
in fairness, since the Earth-838 variant of
the benevolent mutant telepath technically
isn't the same person we see leading the X-Men
in any 20th Century Studios "X-Men" movies,
Stewart could somewhat credibly argue
that he never went back on his word.
Like the rest of the Illuminati, Earth-838
Professor X finds himself utterly overwhelmed
by the Scarlet Witch, who creeps up
behind him while he's inside Wanda's mind
and snaps his neck like a celery stick. We
wish we could've seen more of Professor X
in the "Multiverse of Madness," especially
after Stewart's authoritative declaration of
"we should tell him the truth" was
so heavily featured in trailers.
Unpredictable explosions of grotesque violence
are a huge part of the appeal of Amazon Prime's
"The Boys." Based on the remains that Homelander
shows to Starlight in "Glorious Five Year Plan,"
it's hard to tell exactly what the
leader of the Seven did to Supersonic.
It looks like Homelander punched his face into his
skull and cut his leg off with his heat vision,
but we can only speculate on the precise
nature of Supersonic's multiple fatal injuries.
Years before winning the American Hero reality
show competition and joining the Seven,
Supersonic had been Starlight's first
boyfriend, and nothing we see on "The
Boys" indicates that he was anything
short of a perfect gentleman. In fact,
his friendship with Starlight and his principled
inclination towards doing the right thing
is exactly what ultimately lands
him in Homelander's crosshairs.
"Stop it. You know how that ends."
Little is known of the winged supe known as
Swatto, other than he was a member of Payback and
a close associate of Solider Boy during the
1980s. While his demise was needless and tragic,
it provides a teachable moment for the rest of us.
It's important to remember certain abilities are
less useful than others in specific situations.
In this instance, while the power of hovering
flight is handy for rescuing cats from trees,
it’s utterly worthless against
enemies wielding anti-air artillery.
We know Payback's 1984 mission in Nicaragua is
primarily notable for the disappearance of Soldier
Boy and subsequent government cover-up. However,
the fiasco also marks the final moments of Swatto.
The Green Lantern of Sector 2813 made his first
comic book appearance in the early 1960s and has
remained a consistent supporting cast member
in comics, animated series, and video games.
Tomar-Re is fairly significant relative to
the hundreds of other DC characters who've
been created over the years. And talking
about him as if he might as well be a red
shirt from "Star Trek: The Original Series" is
a little preposterous. Nevertheless, it happens
to be the case that the "Young Justice" version of
Tomar-Re is killed battling Lor-Zod on New Genesis
in the Season 4 episode, "Odyssey of Death!"
While he's introduced a few episodes earlier,
he doesn't get a ton of time in the
spotlight before the curtains fall.
That said, he makes the most of the few moments
he does have onscreen. Tomar-Re explains that
his failure to prevent the destruction
of Krypton has haunted him for decades.
See, he knew and admired Superman's biological
father, Jor-El. While Tomar-Re himself doesn't
survive Lor-Zod's assault, he does manage to
save New Genesis from sharing Krypton's fate and
wraps up his tenure in the universe
with a little bit of redemption.
One of the ex-Payback members
who betrays Soldier Boy,
Crimson Countess might be one of the most bearable
affiliates of the original Vought super-team.
Naturally, there's some degree of narcissism
and a savior complex motivating her advocacy
for endangered chimpanzees, but at least
she channels her personality shortcomings
in a positive direction. Though the fact that
these days she calls a small trailer her home,
perhaps her one true weakness
is sound financial investing.
Speaking of her trailer, that's where
she's blasted off the face of existence
by an exploding Soldier Boy, a fate
shared by numerous characters in the
third season of Amazon's pitch-black
superhero satire. Maybe it's a little
cold to turn your boyfriend over to hostile
military scientists, but at the end of the day,
wasn't helping put Soldier Boy out
of commission the right thing to do?
We don't spend a ton of time with
Blue Hawk on "The Boys." He's only
in a few episodes and mostly exists to
serve as a ruthless commentary on how
American police have handled the deaths
of George Floyd and numerous others.
"I go where the crime is, and the crime
just happens to be in Black neighborhoods."
Blue Hawk swears he's not racist, but he also
insists that hip hop doesn't count as real music.
He went all the way down the birtherism
rabbit hole during the Obama administration
and frequently bemoans the perceived unfairness
of his inability to say racial slurs in public
without social consequences. A-Train has
made some unfortunate choices over the years,
but breaking the sound barrier while
dragging Blue Hawk across the pavement
probably isn't on his list of regrets.
The TNT Twins were former members of
Payback who, when they held hands,
could shoot lightning-like bursts at baddies, but
that's definitely not what we remember them for.
More memorably, the TNT Twins are the
hosts of Herogasm in "The Boys" Season 3.
As we see from a flashback to the 1980s,
they were essentially useless in serious
combat situations. Back in their heyday,
the TNT Twins shot a little laser that made
a big noise and could knock people over,
meaning virtually any ranged weapon would've been
more effective than their so-called superpowers.
As a result, they functioned a little more
like television personalities than what we
typically think of as superheroes. By the time
Soldier Boy catches up to them at Herogasm,
their powers no longer work at all due to
years of neglect. By the end of their lives,
Tommy and Tessa are more like aging circus
performers than one-time crime fighters.
So even if you don't approve
of their lifestyle choices,
one has to wonder if they really deserve to
be victims of Soldier Boy's homicidal rampage.
In the latest "Thor" movie, Jane Foster
is dying of cancer while she devotes her
dwindling existence to defending innocent
people from all manner of cosmic threats.
"I just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there."
However, "Thor: Love and Thunder" is only partly
Jane's movie, for pretty understandable reasons.
Chris Hemsworth is still very much the star
of the show. In the continuity of the MCU,
Jane spent several years away from the
spotlight, but the latest film in the
franchise sees her triumphant return, this
time as more than a basic love interest.
Sometime after her experiences in 2011's "Thor"
and 2013's "Thor: The Dark World," Jane Foster
breaks up with intergalactically acknowledged hunk
Thor. Following a diagnosis of late-stage cancer,
Jane finds herself drawn to the Asgardian hammer
Mjolnir, which declares her worthy and transforms
her into the Mighty Thor. Tragically, the magic
hammer is unable to cure her illness. In fact,
using the weapon is actually hurting her. But she
chooses to pick up Mjolnir and save her Asgardian
boyfriend right as he's about to meet his fate.
As a result of her selfless decision, she dies
shortly after the final confrontation with Gorr
the God Butcher, and is welcomed to Valhalla.
While we lost numerous heroes, a few
villains also didn't survive 2022.
With so many supervillains hatching
so many devious plots at all times,
you'd think there'd be no original
scheme for world domination left untried.
Orm the Ocean Master from "Young Justice"
is basically Loki, with far less charisma,
but let's give him credit, he attempts what
truly seems to be an original evil plan.
Correctly guessing he could charm the people
of Atlantis by embodying an imagined glorious
past, Ocean Master transplants his
consciousness into a clone of Arion,
the original leader of the undersea kingdom.
Ocean Master wins major battles and makes
plenty of inspiring speeches. To cover
his bases, he also clones himself
and loads that clone up with memories, so only
an expert mind reader could sniff out his ruse.
"This is your chance to redeem
yourself before the light."
"And achieve everything I have ever dreamt of."
As it happens, the "Young Justice" crew includes
prominent telepath M'gann M'orzz , who easily
figures out what's up. But by the time M'gann
warns the Atlanteans of Ocean Master's presence in
Arion's body at the end of Season 4's "Leviathan
Wakes," it's too late. "Arion" is declared the
new king of Atlantis. Luckily, thanks to an
ancient prophecy involving the Lords of Order and
Vandal Savage, "Arion" spectacularly explodes
the instant he puts the crown on his head.
Longtime arch-nemesis to Bruce Wayne
and scary grandpa to Damian Wayne,
Ra's al Ghul is assassinated at the onset of DC's
"Shadow War" event, causing plenty
of readers to roll their eyes.
Not only does Ra's, the centuries-old one-time
leader of the League of Assassins, benefit from
the same squishy relationship with mortality
that keeps the rest of DC and Marvel's denizens
uniquely prone to resurrections, immortality
is kind of his whole deal. In the past, when
injuries or illness had Ra's skirting the edges of
the great beyond, he'd retreat to the Lazarus Pit,
a literal fountain of youth, and regenerate
his body into that of a younger, healthier
megalomaniacal eco-terrorist. Basically, Ra's al
Ghul dying and not coming back is kind of like
if the Joker stopped doing murders and laughing
at ironically morbid circumstances. It just
feels wrong even if it's clearly a positive
development for the citizens of Gotham City.
But implausible as it seems, after "Shadow War," a
multi-title crossover penned by Joshua Williamson,
Ra's al Ghul remains as apparently
deceased as he does at the beginning.
Damian is still pretty messed up
about the death of Alfred Pennyworth,
and now he's lost his literal grandfather
shortly after his surrogate grandfather.
When the mercenary forces of Talia al Ghul
and Deathstroke throw down in "Shadow War,"
a lot of them die, including Respawn. The
promising young killing machine debuts
in the League of Lazarus deathmatch
tournament seen in the pages of 2021's
"Robin." He initially appears to have lifted
his costume style and gimmick from Deathstroke.
But Respawn is much more than a
Slade Wilson fanboy. Ra's al Ghul,
being an utterly insane scientific genius,
mixed genetic material from his daughter Talia
and Deathstroke to create the mercenary. Damian
Wayne is initially psyched to find out he has a
half-brother, but his excitement is short-lived.
Shortly after the two meet, Respawn hurls
himself in front of a hail of bullets
and various other projectile weapons intended for
Slade, and as a result, he is ripped to shreds.
Over the years, "Young Justice" has done
a spectacular job establishing its unique
vision of the Teen Titans, but its takes on the
DC Universe's big bad guys tend to feel a little
traditional. The Light is a pretty faithful
version of the Legion of Doom. Villains linked
with Markovia and Apokolips routinely appear in
other DC animated projects, and the General Zod of
"Young Justice: Phantoms," to his credit, is not a
major departure from Terence Stamp's Zod of yore.
“Come to me, son of Jor-El. Kneel before Zod!"
But that brings us to Lor-Zod, elder
Zod's savvy and cold-blooded son,
a profoundly dangerous foil for Superboy
and the Legion of Super-Heroes. Lor-Zod
feels like a deranged sociopath who is
specific to "Young Justice." However,
Season 4 ends with Lor-Zod teleporting into a
bomb blast on Mars that vaporizes him immediately,
but that doesn't mean we'll never see him
again. He is a time traveler, after all.
Even if Lor-Zod is permanently toast,
the final moments of "Phantoms" lead us
to believe a hypothetical next season will
definitely not share the uninteresting
villain problems of previous seasons.